joining us now three men who know this
Florida issue better than pretty much
most everyone in the country Barry
Richard is currently Andrew gillum's
attorney he also represented George W
Bush in the 2000 Florida recount miguel
de Grandy was also part of that bush
legal team and joseph clock was Attorney
for Secretary of State Katherine Harris
during that very same recount
representing her against all these legal
challenges Joseph I want to start with
you tonight do you think it's wise for
governor Scott to move on the offensive
as I do against Broward and Palm Beach
counties or is that premature no I don't
think it's premature you got to be you
have to sort of stay ahead of the the
the the flow of what's going on I think
all the I was not aware of the lawsuit
until I drove over here tonight but
obviously all he wants to do is just to
make sure that there is judicial
supervision of what's going on and
things don't happen that ought not
happening Barry I want to go to you
you're representing Andrew Gilliam he
did concede the other night but as you
said earlier tonight I heard you you
said like that's not a it's not contract
I mean it he thought that the moment
warranted a concession but your client
and you say you're watching things very
closely with the vote count last I
checked I think was about 40,000 or so
votes separating Gilliam of course and
Rhonda Santos what are you looking at
tonight
well there's a vast difference between
2000 and now and 2000 recounts were
precipitated by the candidates who had
to request them and got to select which
counties they were in the legislature as
a result of 2000 has significantly
changed Florida Statutes so the
candidates really have nothing to do
with it now if the margin between the
candidates is less than 1/2 a percent is
an automatic so-called machine recount
where the ballots are sent through the
machines again if it's less than a
quarter of a personnel then there's an
automatic statewide a manual recount as
far as mr. Gilliam is concerned he's
just waiting for the system to play
itself itself out this is part of the
electoral
it's part of the vote counting and he'll
accept the results Miguel I want to go
to you I think a lot of people watching
across the country find it very odd this
whole process of the vote count
extending so many days explain to the
viewers why that is with provisional
ballots what those are and moving into
absentee military counts which I
understand in Florida have not been
counted yet
well provisional and absentee and
military absentee x' are one issue but
what we can't understand is why is it
that mail-in ballots and early votes are
still being counted and have not yet
been properly recorded according to our
laws those votes are supposed to be
uploaded the day before election so that
they could be reported half an hour
after the votes closed the same for the
next day so we're at a loss to
understand what's happening in Palm
Beach and Broward and it's the same two
counties that can't seem to get it right
out of our 67 counties in the state of
Florida well what about the concern I
want to go back to you Joseph about
Brenda Snipes in Broward and the concern
that Marco Rubio he was on another
network no he's on our network earlier
tonight and he just was basically laying
waste to what happens in Broward County
the president tweeted out about this
also tonight which we'll put up on the
screen we put it up on the screen and
then I'll go back to you Joseph this is
what the president said tonight he said
law enforcement is looking into another
big corruption scandal having to do with
election fraud and Broward and Palm
Beach Florida Florida voted for Rick
Scott your comment tonight
Joseph well as Barry said our
legislature thought that they addressed
some of the problems to avoid this kind
of thing from happening it's really kind
of embarrassing to the state that we
have to have this kind of thing go on
and as my County my home county is
miami-dade we don't have this kind of
thing happening here
and if you know because miss Snipes
apparently has this cloud hanging over
or
and then if there is indeed ballots that
are now showing up they shouldn't be I
mean the only ballast we should be
waiting for at this point in time are
the military ballots which I understand
have until November 16 so I think you
know we need to make sure that we take
whatever steps are necessary with the
judiciary to protect the integrity of
the system so that we we don't have
these problems and I think Barry will
agree that one of the reasons we still
have this is that we don't have
statewide controls over balloting it's
done early on a county-by-county basis
and that's why you can have these out
while got it okay so Barry you know I
didn't practice election law but I
remember being down in Miami Dade's
during the recount I think I remember
seeing you guys down there at the time
but this is what Rick Scott said this
was just a short while ago referring to
mark Elias in Tallahassee let's watch I
will not sit idly by while unethical
liberals try to steal this election from
the great people of Florida Sarah Nelson
hired one of Hillary Clinton's lawyers
from DC and the first thing he did was
Terry Porter's is here to win the
election now he's here to try to steal
the election and to try to thwart the
will of the voters of Florida barrier
reaction tough words from Rick Scott
tonight he's certainly not going to sit
back and what he believes is going to be
an election stolen from him at the hands
of myths knives well I have no reaction
in the first place I'm not involved in
that race and in the second place it's
not my purpose to become involved in the
political debate
I'm just the lawyer representing a
client legally and those things are
beyond my sphere of of representation oh
the only the old brendan sullivan thing
I'm not talking about it I respect that
good for you Barry that's not what I do
I'm a lawyer I'm representing a client
I gotta represent publicans and
Democrats I didn't say otherwise I
appreciate it
Miguel I want to go to you on this
because obviously we want to protect the
integrity of the vote I agree with
Stacey Abrams and everyone else who said
every vote should count if you
voted you're eligible eligible to vote
your vote should count I think what
people watch this and they like how is
this in the United States of America
that this this kind of stuff seems to
drag on people are talking about this
dragging on another few weeks in Florida
and I think that's what kind of eats
away at people both are Democrats
Republicans and people on the you know
in the middle Laura I can't agree more I
lost my first election to the Florida
House of Representatives by one vote in
1988 so I'm very keen on the fact that
every vote needs to be counted and an
election needs to be tabulated fairly
what concerns us at this point is the
irregularities that are occurring when
we can't view the ballots being for
example the ballots that are damaged
being duplicated which is required by
law in the presence of witnesses and
were denied access to that process
well we're start hearing that in Palm
Beach County there are situations where
they are actually taking you know steps
that are outside of the public domain
that they are divining voter intent when
that is the the exclusive providence of
the canvassing board and putting those
as recorded votes instead of bringing
them to the canvassing board for their
determination in a public process we
should all be very concerned they have
to be verified by the proper channels
not just divine intention divine and by
the way gillum's campaign said put out a
tweet the Gilliam campaign is looking
for volunteers to help cure leftover
ballots what is it what does that mean
Barry since you will talk about your
client we're almost out of time I get it
guys took yer leftover ballots what does
that mean Barry to cure leftover but
yeah that's what your campaign sent out
what does that mean I don't know what it
means okay all right so I don't know
what it means because I because I don't
know what that reference was - it's not
something I'm involved in I'm not trying
to be difficult for you but yeah when I
was asked to come on the show was to
address the differences between the 2000
campaign
which we got it that's that's the point
you made her this one you're asking me
questions that are beyond my no I'm
sorry I didn't know I didn't know you're
so sensitive about what you can't talk
about what the can listen listen I had a
political spokesman who represents
clients if you want to ask me about that
I'm happy to respond well this is a this
is your client
I imagine talking about well you asked
me what you asked me you asked me what a
statement meant would have said cure
ballots that's not good we appreciate it
gentlemen thank you very much for
joining us